you know everybody's talking about
Rachel on The Bachelor she dated a
certain ambient guy in the NBA you did
too didn't you I look I see I know my
history now don't don't try to get away
so much Letoya Luckett plays coy at the
2017 Det Awards about her shared ex with
Rachel Lindsay NBA star Kevin Durant
know what I'm talking about
how happy are you for him to see all the
success the government's having right
now I am I'm excited for my friend I
know how hard he worked for that
championship and to win it and take that
thing home we prayed together about it
several times and I just when you see a
homey win like that it's nothing you I
mean I was like literally almost like in
tears watching because I was so happy
for him so I'm I'm so I'm happy for him
his family and that's that's awesome
Latoya and Kevin were together back in
2012 while the Bachelorette star
recently revealed she dated the Golden
State Warriors player back in college at
the University of Texas in Austin is it
interesting that all of a sudden Rachel
from The Bachelorette start dropping his
name saying that they dated and all this
stuff in your life like huh my dad died
my name is Bennett ain't never been in
it so uh yeah that's all I got to say
about that but you know good luck some
voters
you
you